women and urban communities have
suffered disproportionate socio-economic
effects in the pandemic and
international inequalities have widened
that's according to a major new global
report from the red cross
covert 19 has amplified inequalities
destabilize communities and reverse
development gains made in the past
decades
we will never truly be able to say that
this pandemic is over if the
socioeconomic harms are not addressed
any action will be meaningless if we do
not also consider the consequences of
violence discrimination and exclusion in
an integrated way it will continue to be
a crisis that affects us all
the report highlights some of the worst
consequences of the crisis including
worsening unemployment and loss of
income there's also been an accompanying
increase in food insecurity with
communities globally finding it harder
to feed their families and women in
particular have become more exposed to
sexual and gender-based violence as well
as bearing the brunt of subsequent
mental health impacts
we can go live now to francesco rocker
who's a president of the international
federation of red cross and red crescent
societies welcome to rt
your organization is a unique position
to be able to assess these kind of
impacts if it helps focus people's minds
though did your researchers find any
particularly harrowing stories as they
compiled their
but report there are several what struck
me the most was um reading about uh the
situation and the survey conducted uh in
el salvador for example about the women
conditioner during the lockdown
and what was really hard to read
it was that uh
an increased number of young teenagers
uh as a result of the the lockdown uh
they they were pregnant and uh
so we we we had a lot of evidence
that uh during uh during the lockdown
and the most
in the hardest part of the confinement
and the measures that were adopted to
contain the virus the spread of the
virus
the women
in latin america but not only there
unfortunately uh were really exposed to
the
sexual
violence
and
and they were also exposed to the mental
health consequences uh of
of the the the um
consequences uh uh on of the of the
uh
of the coming 19 and and uh
and this unfortunately is happening once
again because i call this the
ultimate evidence
about about the women and being affected
by the crisis what do we need more to
understand that we have to to do
something uh something more to protect
the most vulnerable especially women and
and children uh during uh during the
crisis we knew these
they are in a conflict we knew these in
the natural disasters or when they are
forced to migrate
and now
this is uh
the last evidence
what i wanted to ask was when the
pandemic hits there was very much a
sense as a planet we were all in this
together we all had to deal with it and
yet as your reports found some sections
of society have been left behind in this
why have certain groups been harder
hit because they were still
uh living in difficult condition they
had the state
are
often those were living in a difficult
condition before the crisis and once
again this this uh pandemic has proved
it
and uh
so the most marginalized groups
women and children as i said
in the especially in the developing
countries but not only even in the
western countries this has been very
very uh very clear now in the in the
urban settings in the uman areas
these as uh the number of
vulnerabilities
has happened especially in the most
difficult neighborhoods the hardest to
reach so
this is something that continued to
happen and unfortunately despite all the
calls that we we made not only us but
the humanitarian community to the call
to the government to act and to do more
to protect the most vulnerable
unfortunately so far
they are still living the consequences
of the crisis and why have women being
disproportionately affected and not just
in the poorer countries as you say
but look uh this is part of the very sad
legacy that we are living about the role
of the women in the society and uh and
then once again
they are often the one dedicated uh to
take care of the of the of the family
and then plus to take care of those
affected by the covey 19 this unfair
approach to the role of the women
in many many societies
has created the condition for this
perfect storm as a consequences of the
of the of the pandemic
plus uh when when it comes to the to the
jobs and the market of the uh job market
the women
are often employed in the formal sector
and once again
the informal tax sector is one of the of
the the most exposed to the confinement
and and lock down so they were they the
more the first among the first to lose
the
the income the job and the opportunities
all with the supply chain because many
rural areas women are those who are
following him and the agriculture and
the loss of our livelihoods in uh
and then and that's it this is why the
condition of women is i was weak before
the crisis and that then the crisis
uh has created uh the damn even more
weak
one suspects that at the moment instead
of thinking as a wider community either
in people's own towns or countries or
continents that people think largely of
themselves and that there's a great
scramble to get back where they were and
it'll be a survival of the most
successful what will determine
communities speed of recovery from all
this
it's uh for me but this is my personal
thought i don't know if i can talk as a
president of the international
federation but i think a new leadership
people uh who really are able to reunite
and to unify and to build new values so
here we must use
this uh opportunity to transform the
tragedy of the pandemic
in an important opportunity to create a
new fabric of the society to build the
society around around values and
principle that it seems we are losing
and this is something that that for me
is extremely extremely vital and then we
also we must not forget one other aspect
that is also affecting the the the
rebuild of the of the society and to to
live as a community at global level is
the vaccine inequity so we are here in
the western western country we are
administering the third dose to our
communities a while in the developing
countries they are still at 10 15 and 20
percent and so how we can talk about a
global recovery if
we are living at this
huge inequality uh when it comes to the
concrete facts that should happen and
should come from from the global leaders
indeed if there's one thing to draw from
this report it's that humanity's way out
is not going to be through selfishness
we really appreciate your time joining
us on rt francesca rocker president of
the international federation of red
cross and red crescent societies thanks
very much
you